den beginn der russischen aggression
gegen die ukraine dieses meeting dieses
gespräch war
einfach und zugleich schwierig einfach
weil minister lawrow im wesentlichen
seine traditionell negative über die
ukraine vorgetragen hat schwierig weil
ich
mein bestes gegeben habe um
zumindest eine diplomatische lösung zu
finden für die humanitäre tragödie die
sich vor unseren augen entfaltet auf dem
schlachtfeld in den belagerten städten
die tragische situation entwickelt sich
gerade in der stadt mario pohl am
asowschen meer
die stadt wird aus der luft bombardiert
sie liegt unter artilleriebeschuss
und ich kam hierher
mit humanitären zielen
ich wollte hier vereinbarungen erreichen
für die einrichtung humanitärer
korridore in die stadt mario pohl unter
hier aus der stadt hinaus aus der stadt
hinaus für zivilisten die aus der
belagerten stadt aus dem gebiet von
angst und kampf zu fliehen wollen und
einen humanitären korridor der es
ermöglicht humanitäre hilfsgüter in die
stadt zu bringen leider
war minister wurf nicht in der lage sich
selbst darauf zu verpflichten aber
er wird mit den
entsprechenden autoritäten in russland
darüber konferieren wir haben auch die
frage einer 24 stunden waffenruhe
aufgeworfen um die dringendsten
humanitären probleme zu lösen
wir haben keinen fortschritt in dieser
frau erzielt denn wie es scheint werden
diese entscheidungen von anderen in
russland getroffen
wir haben vereinbart
unsere bemühungen fortzusetzen
um eine lösung nach lösungen zu suchen
für die humanitären probleme im inland
ich bin bereit mich erneut zu treffen
mit minister labors in diesem format
wenn es aussichten gibt auf
substanzielle diskussion
und auch die ernsthafte suche nach
lösungen ich glaube wenn zwei
außenminister sich treffen dann
haben sie per definitionem das mandat
über frieden sicherheit und andere
fragen zu verhandeln dass man da das ist
in ja von ihren parlamenten anvertraut
worden und von ihrer politischen führung
und ich bin bereit
auf diesem wege weiter zu verhandeln mit
dem ziel den krieg in der ukraine zu
beenden
das leid der ukrainischen zivilisten zu
beenden und
unser
gebiet von den russischen
besatzungstruppen zu befreien ich werde
nun ein paar worte auf ukrainisch
vortragen
[Musik]
wir hatten
kollegen der türkischer kollege
hat
eine gute arbeit geleistet und hohe
professionalität in seinen medien
dieses gespräch
ich bin zu diesen gesprächen gekommen
mit zwei aufgaben das wäre das erste
wäre die einrichtung von den humanitären
korridor für
die belagerten zivilisten in mache opel
weil
die humanitäre lage in dieser stadt ist
prekär und
meine zweite aufgabe wäre die
vereinbarung von dem 24-stündigen
waffenstillstandes
in puncto rheins
hoffe ich dass minister lawrow wird
darüber mit den verantwortlichen
personen in russland sprechen und wir
das doch auch die wege bringen können
ich hoffe dass die russische föderation
aus aber ein menschlichen
überlegungen aus mitleid zu den
zivilisten die unter russischen
überschüssen leiden darunter auch die
babys
tausende von denen jetzt auf der
schwelle des todes schweben
dass die russen eben aus diesen
überlegungen
die einrichtung des humanitären woche
durchaus mario pahl
einrichten wir dasselbe gilt auch für
die stadt summe
[Musik]
wir können leider den krieg wir werden
den krieg nicht aufhalten können
und da der ukrainische aussenminister im
prinzip das was auf englisch schon
gesagt hat jetzt auf ukrainisch
wiederholt denke ich können wir sein
statement verlassen weil jetzt der
russische außenminister lawrow auf seine
pressekonferenz beginnt
auf antrag der türkischen seite der
türkische präsident erdogan hat neulich
mit dem präsidenten putin gesprochen und
hat diese initiative aufgegriffen wir
haben diesen vorschlag der türkischen
kollegen aufgegriffen denn wir sind für
jegliche kontakte zu den problemen die
heutzutage dem ukrainischen der
ukrainischen krise zugrunde liegen es
betrifft auch die wege aus der krise das
einzige was wir gleich gekennzeichnet
haben dieser kunst sagte müssen einen
mehrwert bringen und wir gehen davon aus
dass diese kontakte nicht dafür benutzt
werden von unseren ukrainischen kollegen
die solche sachen regelmäßig machen
diese kontakte werden nicht dafür
genutzt um zu der viren die realen
wirklichen verhandlungen die auf dem
belorussischen boden stattfinden und
sich entwickeln auf der ebene von zwei
delegationen lief von den präsident uns
von belarus und russland in ihrem amt
bestätigt worden sind und das heutige
gespräch hat erneut bestätigt dass
dieser track dieser weg alternativlos
bleibt der in weißrussland wir haben
heute uns vor allem über die ic bei der
türkischen freunde ausgetauscht
humanitären fragen wir haben auch
erklärt welche massnahmen von unserem
boden drogen aufgegriffen werden um
den zivilisten in der ukraine zur
unterstützung der menschen die
weitestgehend
geworden sind die von den sogenannten
freiwilligen bataillons ausgenutzt
werden und auch die anderen
verteidigungskräfte die werden als
lebendiger schuldtiteln aber all diese
fakten all diese tatsachen die werden
mehrfach pro tag unter anderem auch von
unseren auswärtigen amt und dem
verteidigungsministerium mitgeteilt
wir haben bestätigt dass die initiative
die ihrerseits von russland geäußert
wurde zur öffnung von humanitären
korridors diese initiative bleibt in
kraft die routen von solchen korridors
die zeit der eröffnung werden bestimmt
von denjenigen die die situation am
boden kontrollieren und im griff haben
die analysieren die situation umgehen
von der notwendigkeit der meistens
effizienten roten für die zivilisten zu
finden
und natürlich erinnere haben wir unsere
ukrainischen kollegen daran erinnert
dass bei der letzten runde der
verhandlungen in belarus die russische
seite ganz konkrete schon
projektbezogene dokumente vorgestellt
und überlegungen und die ukrainische
seite hat diese vorschläge übernommen
nach kiew gebracht und hat uns
versichert dass wir in der nächsten zeit
eine konkrete antwort darauf bekommen
werden denn sie haben möchten einem
gespräch in belarus führen zwar
ernsthaft die formal nicht dass wir uns
gegenseitig mit
unverbindlichen papieren loswerden
sondern dass wir die vorschläge
bestätigen die im allgemeinen kontext
der lösung der ukrainischen krise
verwendet werden müssen im kontext der
gewährleistung der sicherheit auf dem
europäischen kontinent
dabei müssen natürlich alle seiten aller
länder berücksichtigt werden mit ihren
interessen das in kürze worüber wird
heute gesprochen haben jetzt bin ich
bereit ihre fragen zu beantworten
ob wir da jemanden haben von den
kollegen vom russischen fernsehen
dann anadolu die türkische seite bekommt
recht auf die erste frage
haben sie die kosten die für die
russische föderation entstehen
ausgerechnet
[Musik]
kosten
errechnet uns haben sie mehr kosten oder
weniger
das war die erste frage
haben sie haben sie vor auch außerhalb
der ukrainischen grenzen eine operation
durchzuführen
und haben sie auch eine option offen
wegen militärischer
dedizierten zurückschlagen in der
übersetzung aber
wenn ich die frage beantwortet dazu
die sonderoperation sich entwickeln soll
werden diese einschätzungen vor allem
von den vertretern vom
verteidigungsministerium gegeben und
natürlich der präsident hat mehrfach
unterstrichen dass die operation nach
plan abläuft was die waffenlieferung in
die ukraine anbelangt aus dem ausland
wir sehen die
post ja wie gefährlich es ist was unsere
westlichen kollegen machen inklusive
weil die europäische union krieg gegen
alle grundwerte und einer so genannten
grundsätze der faktor waffenlieferungen
für tödliche waffen
unterstützt einschließlich tausende von
zenit komplexen die man einfach von der
schulter bewegt bewegen kann an jeden
ort und sie auch sehr oft von
terroristen benutzt worden sind um eine
gefährdung
der flugzeug der zivilluftfahrt so
machen wohin diese waffen später das ist
die frage die wir unseren kollegen von
stellen und so in der europäischen union
wenn die interesse daran wie man
ende der politik machen könnte die
ukraine
ausgefahren wurde nämlich eine
gefährdung der russischen föderation
bis jetzt haben wir noch keine antwort
darauf wie dieser waffen demnächst
kontrollieren das heißt wir haben eine
gefährdung eine gefahr für viele weitere
leite für zivilflugzeuge und das nicht
nur in der ukraine im ukrainischen
himmel sondern auch europa weiter groß
was ihre frage anbelangt ob wir planen
weitere länder zu überfallen nein das
planen wir nicht wir haben auch keine
nicht überfallen
haben wir mehrfach erklärt wir haben
eine situation die unmittelbare
gefährdung für die sicherheit der
russischen föderation
unseren mehrjährigen aufrufen und
vorschlägen hat uns keiner gehört
präsident putin hat mehrfach sich zu
diesem thema geäußert und die neuen
tatsachen die wir jetzt erfahren auch
den befreiten gebieten der ukraine unter
anderem internets und lohans gewinnt
bestätigt dass der überfall auf die
volksrepublik schon längst sorgfältig
geplant war und zwar schon in diesem
monat im laufenden monat und natürlich
die zu ist absolut widerlich und
enttäuschend das pentagon
betreibt
angesicht der geologie biologie waffen
laboren auf dem ukrainischen boden da
experimentiert mit pathogenen stoffen
die später für biologische waffen
benutzt werden können dass die vertreter
von washington publik dass widerlegt
haben sollen diese gerüchte wie sie
sagen dass sie irgendwelche verbote
tätigkeit in der ukraine zu betreiben
darüber braucht man sich nicht zu
wundern dass die europäische union mit
einer stimme sagt auch die hätten keine
informationen
über die tätigkeit der amerikaner in
diesem gebiet der biologischen waffen
das wundert uns nicht und was die
vertreter der uno gesagt haben sie
hätten auch keine informationen
diesbezüglich auch das wundert uns
nichts denn natürlich haben die
amerikaner haben diese tätigkeit
insgeheim betrieben genauso wie sie in
anderen staaten des postsowjetischen
raumes arbeiten indem sie die laboren
rund um die russische föderation gründen
auch in der chinesischen republik in der
chinesischen volksrepublik das sind
tatsachen
ist nicht zu widerlegen es gibt eine
internationale konvention zum verbot von
biologischen waffen und deswegen müssen
alle staaten
bericht erstatten der weltöffentlichkeit
über tätigkeit in dieser richtung wenn
ich ihre frage richtig verstanden habe
so ist meine antwort aber diejenigen die
waffen in die ukraine pumpen müssen uns
schon verstehen dass sie verantwortung
für ihre handlungen tragen genauso wie
diejenigen
die weitere soldaten söldner in die
ukraine schicken oder
sie unterstützen damit die
rechtsradikalen in der ukraine
eine frage von 10 bis
eine frage von cbc news
events
russland
hat verschiedene worte benutzt um die
invasion in der ukraine zu rechtfertigen
sie sagen das sei für das ukrainische
volk aber die können sie die
bombardierung
eines entbindung heinz und eine
verbindungs krankenhauses und eines
kinderkrankenhauses recht fertig
also kinder und schwangere frauen zu
bombardieren ist doch ein
kriegsverbrechen und russlands selbst
hat mit enormen zahlungsausfällen zu
rechnen also die russische wirtschaft
geht schlimmer in die knie atir zuvor
können sie den leuten gegen rechtfertigt
dass ihre wirtschaft ruinieren für einen
in version an die die rest der welt
nicht glaubt
bindungs kliniken anbelangt nicht zum
ersten mal haben wir mit pathetischen
ausrufen zu tun es bezüglich die
sogenannten untaten von
russischen militärs
am 17 märz vor drei tagen
um 17 uhr am 6 ich kann es jetzt nicht
genau sagen beim bei der sitzung vom
uno-sicherheitsrat
wurden tatsachen von unserer delegation
vorgelegt dazu dass dieses krankenhaus
in bildungs krankenhaus schon längst vom
bataillon azoff und anderen radikalen
besetzt worden ist alle schwangeren
frauen alle
krankenschwester und ärzte sind da
vertrieben wurden und es wurde benutzt
von also von ultra radikalen militärs
von dem bataillon als auf diese
tatsachen haben wir bereits vor drei
tagen vorgelegt machen sie ihre
schlussfolgerungen selber wie in
manipuliert wie die öffentliche meinung
in der ganzen welt gerade manipuliert
wird ich habe heute auch eine reportage
auch bei ihnen dazu gesehen auch in
anderen westlichen massenmedien
es ist sehr emotional aber leider ist
die andere seite
sind in dieser situation
seite die erlaubt eine objektive meinung
sich zu bilden diese anderer seite die
hat nicht wirklich verachtet
was den zustand der us-wirtschaft der
russischen föderation anbelangt wissen
sie darum werden wir uns schon selber
kümmern darum kümmert sich der präsident
für unsere regierung
sind nur noch einmal davon überzeugt
worden sie sagen sie wir benutzen viele
worte um zu rechtfertigen was wir gerade
in der ukraine tun
wir
haben berücksichtigt wir haben
längst gesagt in der ukraine passiert
das was man in russland schon seit
jahren zu gehen versucht wenn der westen
seit anfang 2000 jahren von den
ukrainern verlangt grad vor jedem wahlen
sich festzulegen sind in mit russland
oder mit dem westen das heißt entweder
oder bist du mit uns oder bist du gegen
uns was sind das für westliche werte
hinein geblasen werden in die köpfe der
ukrainischen menschen der sokratischen
volkers wir beobachten auch
manipulationen in den der sogenannte
prowestlicher kandidat wir zusätzlich
als letzter landete wie es 2009 der fall
war als die künstler durch gegen die
verfassung der verfassung der ukraine
musste in der ukraine kostenlose anti
konstitutionelle entscheidung getroffen
werden eine dritte runde die wahlen zu
veranstalten diese manipulationen gab es
in allen jahren immer wieder keiner hat
in den jahren jemand dann wird rot-grün
aber immer wieder wurde ukraine zu einem
pro- westlichen experiment experiment
instrument geschaffen
wurde zu einem instrumenten ausgebildet
und als nato dann auch verlangt dass du
keine auch die ganze freiheit hätte sich
nato anzuschließen als in der ukraine
schon
bald als ausstellungen geschaffen wurden
als unmittelbar bedrohen des führungs
nach stationiert wurden und jetzt wieder
wir sind auch biologische waffen in den
laboren entwickelt wurden auch das wurde
den ukrainischen menschen unterwelt
öffentlichkeit verheimlicht heimlich
teures und als der ukraine aus auch auf
den amazon freien staates verzichten
musste dann haben wir aufgerufen
aufgerufen zum gewissen umzug vernunft
unserer westlichen partner denn es geht
um sicherheit auf dem europäischem boden
in europa und man hat uns gesagt ihr
könnt reden was er wollte aber die frage
der nato osterweiterung ist unsere sache
das werden wir ohne euch entscheiden und
macht euch keine angst eure sicherheit
wird nicht bedroht aber deswegen warum
sollen die fragen unserer sicherheit und
interessen der russischen föderation von
natur entschieden werden wenn die uns
versichern wir werden nicht vertraut man
mit russland kann man so nicht reden
deswegen
sind wir nicht daran interessiert unsere
handlungen in der ukraine zu
rechtfertigen wir haben diese handlungen
vorgestellt wir haben ganz konkrete
vorschläge gemacht wir wollen keine
militarisierung der ukraine ob mit oder
ohne nato man kann auch ohne nato der
amerikanische raketen
stationieren die russland im visier
haben
wir wollen nicht die tendenz aus
erhalten des aufbaus von einem
nazistischen neonazistischen staat mit
neonazistischen stationen auf dem
ukrainischen boden mit
marschierenden ss truppen die
den präsidenten salutieren und einiges
mehr
wenn diese
terroristen trainiert werden um ihre
taten zu verüben und natürlich wollen
wir dass ukraine 1 neutrales land bleibt
shooting präsident putin hat mehrfach
gesagt er
bestätigt sie wollen wir darauf bestehen
dass nach dass ich nicht arbeiten wollen
wir nicht den ukrainern ihr recht auf
sicherheit absprechen wir sind bereit
die garantien für die ukrainische
sicherheit abzusprechen aber im kontext
der sicherheit der anderen europäischen
länder und russland und das jetzt
wasilewski gerade gesprochen hat dass
langsam die klarheit darüber
durchsickert das macht uns gedämpft
optimistisch was unsere wirtschaftlichen
problemen beladen werden wir schon im
griff kriegen wir haben auch andere
schwierigkeiten bewältigt auf allen
etappen unserer geschichte als diese
schwierigkeiten entstanden sind aber
diesmal ich möchte sie versichern wir
kommen aus dieser krise
sie kommen mit einer gestärkten
psychologie und einer klaren vorstellung
illusion frei darüber ob westen zu einem
sicheren partner werden kann wir haben
keine illusionen mehr darüber dass der
besten wenn über die werte gesprochen
wird es wird daran nicht geglaubt und
wir sind ganz sicher der westen wird
jedes verraten in jedem moment sogar
sich selbst und eigene werte denn buch
hat man sonst gehören das eigentumsrecht
so mit füßen getreten werden könnte
gerade wie könnte man früher sehen dass
unschuldsvermutung ist also das
rechtssystem des westens dermaßen
ignoriert wird und grob verletzt
ich versichere sie hier wir haben unsere
probleme überwältigen können aber wir
tun alles damit wir nie wieder vom
westen in den gebieten abhängen die
entscheidung sind für unser volk
jetzt kanal als russisches fernsehen
möchte ein zitat aus tief bringen die
heute der stellvertretende chef des
präsidialamtes hat gesagt er ist bereits
so diplomatischen lösung aber die
ernsthaften verhandlungen mit den russen
sind nur möglich auf den ebenen der
beiden präsidenten halten sie es für
sinnvoll jetzt oder in der nächsten zeit
ein treffen von den beiden
staatspräsidenten zu organisieren die
antwort alle wissen ganz genau auf
präsident putin und leni kontakte ab wir
wollen nur dass diese kontakte
wären nicht der kontakte als solchen
segen sondern damit wir bestimmte
entscheidungen und abkommen dabei
festhalten können wir haben dieses thema
heute mit herrn kollegen
angesprochen herr kollege hat auch diese
themen erwähnt diese auch gerade kabinen
ich habe daran erinnert wir sind immer
dafür dass wir uns treffen aber nur dann
wenn wir ein mehrwert dabei erzeugen
können und eine problemlösung
herbeirufen können die ukrainische
führung
nachdem eine position allen
verfassungswidrigen umsturz von 2014
imitiert oder simuliert
konkrete entscheidungen
mit neuen kontakten
mit fernsehkameras bei laufenden kameras
ich erinnere noch einmal an sieben
minsker abkommen blockiert worden sind
von der von dem kiewer regime präsident
selensky hat damals immer wieder
aufgetreten lass uns treffen dass es
endlich zusammen kommen noch einmal als
wir die ukrainischen kollegen daran
erinnert haben dass 2019 entschuldigung
2009 in dieser stadt eintreffen
normandie format gab und alle fragen an
schief und keiner der entscheidung wurde
umgesetzt dann gab es kam es nie dazu
aufrufen lassen ist schon wieder treffen
und dann werden wir die entscheidungen
von paris erzielen aber warum haben wir
uns in paris getroffen wenn wir noch
einsame durchführen müssen und damit die
entscheidungen umgesetzt werden das
heißt dieser strategie
in den kern der probleme zu ersetzen
durch äußere effekte wie nochmal die
format muss es größer werden muss es
kleiner werden müssen die briten die
polen die amerikaner aber auge die
türkei mit am tisch sitzen dann gab es
noch eine andere idee
dass die franzosen und die deutschen
sich auch daran beteiligen also es war
ein bruder von immer neuen ideen aber
all diese ideen sind einfach zu erklären
sie wollen keine richtigen handlungen
für die umsetzung von eigenen
entscheidungen treffen sondern die
erzeugen nur effekt der präsident putin
hat nichts gegen ein treffen mit dem
präsidenten syriens kirchhofer dass die
notwendigkeit von einem solchen treffen
wirklich entstehen wird aber dafür muss
ich die vorbereitungsarbeit durchgeführt
werden und das läuft über den
belarussischen weg es sind schon mehrere
treffen stattgefunden unsere konkreten
vorschläge liegen vor die ukrainische
seite hat uns konkrete antworten
versprochen auf die warten wir gerade
wir haben auch vertreter
von den ukrainischen medien von dem
öffentlichen fernsehen der ukraine
russland
als die nazi führung für die nets
finanzierung grundkonsens zu
reibungen und folter ob es in creme
waren wir den bayerischen bevölkerung im
süden amazon sind mehrere frauen
gekidnappt worden auch die tataren leila
ibrahim o war eine abgeordnete das heißt
sie haben in diesen acht jahren früher
hatten sie wir sind an einer neuen ebene
angekommen sie kidnappen jetzt trauen es
ist wichtig dass wir unsere türkischen
kollegen wissen dass jetzt
krimtataren abläuft das ist meine
kindheit region da bin ich aufgewachsen
die antwort lautet sie reden von
tatsachen aber ich würde dafür ein
anderes wort mit f finden nämlich fake
news ist internet und massenmedien
gerade überfüllt ich habe von dieser
geschichte dieser quasi entführung
nichts gehört eine abgeordneten aber ich
weiß
über die manieren
für die region von tief berühmt ist ich
habe gestern gehört der abgeordnete
schewtschenko wäre verschwunden ist
dabei vielleicht schon gefunden
der an den verhandlungen in kiel
beteiligt war ist umgebracht worden
erstmals aus der ära von
sicherheitsdiensten der ukraine
hingerichtet während vorstandsberater
dann hieß es es kam zu einer
auseinandersetzung
das heißt wenn man sich in individuelle
geschichten vertieft kann man vieles
empören viel empörendes und enttäuschend
das zu tage fördern aber wenn wir eine
episode nehmen und diese wenn man diese
eine episode nimmt die oft eher dunkel
und falsch ist und damit die öffentliche
meinung versucht es braucht zum kochen
zu bringen um antirussische politik zu
betreiben unter anderem in der türkei da
haben wir wieder
versucht zu tun durch
effekte eine ernsthafte ein ernsthaftes
gespräch zu ersetzen
man kann viele namen und nachnamen
aufzählen also
ich habe nur gesagt ich werde mich als
präsident aber ich habe von diesem fall
nicht gehört dafür habe ich von
schewtschenko der in sapporo sie hier
verschwunden ist entschuldigung
entschuldigung es ist eine
pressekonferenz
ist es wichtig dass auch andere kollegen
fragen stellen können
ich glaube sie haben schon ihre bilder
sie werden schon in ihrer heimat im
fernsehen gezeigt sie haben ihr ziel
bereits erreicht jetzt die italienischen
kollegen bitte die frage
italienern gesprochen da ist kein
jurist dr kollegen
lieber mache ich hier gibt es demokratie
jeder der das mikro an sich reichen kann
macht das
gibt hin stimmen die sagen es seien
biologische waffen bei dem angriff
eingesetzt worden was sagen sie dazu
sehr darüber besorgt über die tatsache
dass
einige dutzende von biologischen laboren
auf dem boden der ukraine gegründet hat
im rahmen seines programms für die
entwicklung der biologischen waffen
weltweiten schäden das ist ein verstoß
gegen die entsprechende konvention über
den verbund verbot der toxischen waffen
wir haben eine entsprechende anfrage
gerichtet und wir wollen eine erklärung
bekommen
dass sie diese waffen schon eingesetzt
haben dazu habe ich keine fakten keine
tatsachen aber dass es sich um keine
friedlichen experimente handelte sondern
um entwicklung von biologischen waffen
und zwar ethnisch orientierter
biologischer waffen daran habe ich kaum
zweifel lieber also die kollegen von ihr
wisst ja das ist die russische
tageszeitung
zuschauer 70 die usa erklären ganz klar
dass die botschafter
müssen die regierungen der länder der
welt daran überzeugen sich an die anti
russischen sanktionen beteiligen müssen
diese isolation von russland von dem
westen spricht
die ist es
unsere botschafter in jeder situation
werden orientiert von uns wir werden
informieren sie über die tatsachen über
unsere position die sich auf die
jeweilige situation bezieht dass es eine
aufgabe des auswärtigen amtes und unsere
botschafter der russischen föderation
bringen diese information weiter an die
regierungen der länder wo sie russland
vertreten damit ein objektives bild
entsteht in der ganzen welt herum zu
laufen und einen souveränen als
unabhängiges land
zu zwingen
einen aufschlag von dem großen bruder
auszuführen dass sie wird nicht zu
unseren traditionen wir sind gut
erzogene höfliche menschen wie sie
wissen und das was die amerikaner machen
und sie machen kein hehl daraus dass sie
von der türkei verlangen von indien von
ägypten
von südostasiatischen staaten und sogar
von china und sie fordern dass sie
die sanktionen der amerikaner
gesetzeswidriger sanktionen mitmachen so
viel missachtung gegenüber bedeutenden
staaten und großen nationen so was habe
ich mir nicht vorstellen für ein
arbeitstier für die amerikaner scheint
alles gut zu sein um ihre
logische
taten zum zur apotheke zu treiben
nein das sind italienischen scannen und
dann gibt es regional
aus großbritannien sie haben vor einiger
zeit gesagt russland habe keine absicht
ich verdiene zu verfallen heute haben
sie gesagt russland habe die ukraine
nicht überfallen aber es russland hat
die ukraine überfallen sie haben auch
gesagt russland würde keine zivilisten
in mitleidenschaft ziehen aber tausende
und abertausende wurden verletzt und
getötet warum sollten die ukraine sie
überhaupt ernste warum sollten sie ein
wort glauben was sie sagen warum sollte
der rest der welt ihm glauben
bindungs kliniken anbelangt dazu habe
ich mich geäußert aber sie wollen es
nicht hören unter die westlichen medien
werden es nie zeigen dass wir vor drei
tagen im sicherheitsrat bereits erklärt
habe was mit entbindungsklinik passiert
war
wer was machen wird und wer was nicht
machen wird wir haben bis zuletzt
versucht und gewollt das problem auf
diplomatische wege zu lösen wir haben
unterschiedliche dokumente dazu
vorgelegt so ein bilateralen abkommen
mit den usa und usa nato zu allen
schlüssel ist die fragen der
europäischen sicherheit
indem wir die interessen von allen allen
partnern allen ländern europas
berücksichtigt haben einschließlich der
ukraine man hat uns gesagt nein die
ukraine gehört zu uns wir entscheiden
mit der ukraine deren schicksal wir
werden es so tun sie dies wollen auch
viele andere vorschläge von uns wurden
abgelehnt man schließlich nicht
zulassung von erschaffung von physischen
gefahren für die russische föderation
auf dem ukrainischen boden der präsident
putin hat ganz klar erklärt warum er
sich für die sonder operation
entschieden hat ich hoffe auch wenn das
man es ihnen nicht erlaubt dass ihren
hörern und zuschauern zu erzählen
vielleicht lesen sie sich selber ein und
versuchen unsere logik zu verstehen wir
haben es klar dazu geäußert wir brauchen
wir wollen eine die metallisierte
ukraine die freundschaftlich wie uns
gegenüber gestimmt ist ein wo ist keine
gefahrt zur gründung von dem nächsten
nationalsozialistischen staat gibt
eindruck rheine wo es kein verbot für
die russische sprache und russischer
kultur russische orthodoxe kirche gibt
all das hat sich angestaut und
angesammelt all das ist schon der fall
und hat schon wurde schon in den
gesetzen in der ukraine festgehalten all
unsere wünsche all unserer
ansprachen in den letzten acht jahren
dass sie irgendwie mit den ukrainischen
ukrainische regierung reden wurden
abgelehnt wurden verschwiegen
die letzte geschichte mit der russischen
sprache als die das ukrainische gesetz
zur staatlichen sprache für absolut
wurde wo nur die ukrainische sprache
verwendung werden sollte und alle
anderen sprachen
so oder so auch beim unterricht in den
grundschulen und auch an den hochschulen
auf dem verlorenen posten waren und das
war
für uns ein problem sondern auch
rumänien bulgarien haben sich dagegen
geäußert damit haben die ukrainische
macht ganz einfach gehandelt sie haben
eine ausnahme gemacht für die sprachen
der europäischen union dass sie sehr
nett so ist nun die russische sprache
rechtlos geblieben in der ukraine obwohl
in der verfassung der ukraine eigentlich
die rechte für die ukrainische sprache
garantiert sind und der besten hat sich
beruhigt hat nichts gesagt das war ein
erneuter beweis dafür dass der westen
nur eins von der ukraine möchte dass
sogar eine ständig gegen russland arbeit
gegen alles russischen verstehen sie
dass der westen
beim referendum im krieg gemacht hat das
waren so was von doppelter standards als
also zum beispiel in kosova wurde kein
referendum durchgeführt aber nato hat
extra mit den bombardements die
situation erschaffen mit jugoslawien
zerfällt
entscheidung von einem kosovarischen
organ wurde einfach die unabhängigkeit
erklärt der ganze westen oder fast ganz
am besten hat beifall gespendet und hat
das als zeichen der demokratie
bestätigt warum dürfen die russen in
grimmen nicht las dass die albaner in
jugoslawien dürfen der albaner hat man
damit unterstützt das ich in diese
richtung bewegen weil ziel unter anderem
ziel von einem land wie großbritanniens
ist und bleibt
dass man in balkan und auch europaweit
keine zu großen staaten zuletzt das
wissen wir doch ganz genau uns
wahrscheinlich wurde dieser ziel sei es
gefühlt in bezug auf die russische
föderation verfolgt aber ich wiederhole
noch einmal schuldig wir haben früh
genug verstanden es geht nicht um die
ukraine ist es geht um eine aggression
gegen alles russische
interessen durch kultur sprache
sicherheit und anderes und anderes mehr
und jetzt natürlich die reaktion des
westens auf unsere handlungen
entschuldigt mir dieses wort reaktion
die eine hysterische reaktion ist ein
beweis dafür dass
es ist ein kampf
um das recht russlands
macht auf der politischen charakter der
welt zu bleiben mit der unter einhaltung
russischer interessen city wie china
vielen dank der außenminister
eine professur city wie jene der
ukrainische aussenminister sagte k das
aber keine fortschritte jeden zur
waffenruhe meine frage lautet gibt es
irgend ein positives ergebnis aus ihrem
gespräch und was ist ihr plan um die
krise zu entschärfen
wie gesagt
wir sind hierhergekommen
minis nicht
die richtigen verhandlungen zu ersetzen
die von beiden präsidenten geschafft
worden sind und die auf dem teller
russischen boden vor sich gehen
in diesen verhandlungen haben die ja
ganz
eingehend vorgelegt ist was zu tun ist
um diese krise beizulegen also die
militarisierung der notifizierung und da
soll und eben im rahmen von diesen
verhandlungen
weißrussland
gibt es sachliche verhandlungen
haben
vorweg gesagt hier werden wir eine
zweite plattform für die konkrete arbeit
schaffen
verhandlungen um nur die
falschen nachrichten
zu verbreiten und nur sie eigentlich
sagt ich arbeite zu simulieren dass das
ist immer noch meine haltung und ich bin
nichts darüber verwundert dass sie
falsch sind stillstand nicht vereinbart
worden ist es ging ja von anfang an die
nicht um den waffenstillstand
während des heutigen treffen
all dieser vorträge
vorschläge zur
waffenstillstand oder zu den humanitären
korridoren ja das gehört
nicht zu den heutigen
verhandlungen
und das gehört eigentlich zu der typisch
ukrainischen logisch art und weise wie
sie die diplomatische arbeit leisten
also diese art und weise richtet sich
auf die special effects und nicht auf
die konkrete ergebnisse
vielen dank dass ich die frage stellte
ich meine erste frage lautet
es geht ja um die frage des verbots von
russischen öl- und gasimporten wie ist
denn die russische öl politik und gas
politik ging über europa und die zweite
freistellen sanktionen sich reagiert
russland auf die sanktionen von für
unternehmen und ländern
[Musik]
problemlos lösen und mit dem ziel das
wir nie wieder von unseren westlichen
partnern von betrieben und der
regierungen
abhängig werden die
eigentlich zu den instrumenten die
politischen aktionen geworden sind
welcher von von westen
belastet wird und sie wollen in der
zukunft also unabhängig werden dass
niemand
darüber entscheiden könnte
wie unsere wirtschaft zerstört werden
kann
was war das noch
also das war zu den funktionen
also erdgas und erdöl das
überlassen wir also dem gewissen unserer
westlichen partnern wir haben unser gas
und öl nie als eine waffe eingesetzt und
heute wird das uns immer wieder davor
geworden 2010 gab es die erste krise
damals hat der ukrainische staat einfach
die russischen lieferungen
beklaut wir haben immer den erdgas
nach europa geliefert und die ukraine
haben auf dem wege also abgezahlt
das pro und im endeffekt so waren auch
damals
beschuldigt
russland ist daran schuld alles was die
ukraine an sie
hat nur ein kriterium des autos trat
wie kann man durch die ukraine der
russischen föderation schaden
hinzuzufügen russland einzudämmen
ja das ist ganz interessant
das charakterisiert die wette die
europäischen werte
also die europäer sehr schön von
russland die verlegen uns mit den
sanktionen alle fliehen aus russland
aber sagen dabei wissen sie wir kaufen
doch erdgas und erdöl sonst verlieren
gehen im winter
und rhythmisches unseres khartum
stimulieren da hat russland bereits
schon erklärt wir werden unsere partner
nicht dazu überreden bei uns einzukaufen
wir haben für uns andere märkte
schlossen
vielen dank
ich bin vom wall street journal
meine frage lautet hat russland
irgendwelche roten linien im zug auf
militärhilfe wo würden sie eine rote
linie ziehen bevor sie militärische
handeln
ich habe nicht genau gefragt bevor ich
bevor wir militärisch
zu schlagen gegen wen zum beispiel gegen
länder die militärhilfe leisten haben
sie eine rote linie zum beispiel
viele länder schicken ja jetzt
militärische hilfsgüter an die ukraine
haben sie eine rote linie im hinblick
auf militärisch militärhilfe für die
ukraine bevor sie selber dagegen
vorgehen da habe ich schon ein watt
beantwortet ob wir auf solches vorgehen
reagieren werden
wir sind der meinung
dieser länder schaffen
enorme gefahren für sich selbst
besonders wenn sie ganz gefährliche
waffen an die ukraine liefern zum
beispiel die portablen die mobile
abwehrraketen komplexe
und in der ukraine werden zum beispiel
die skis waffen wahllos sind die
bevölkerung verteilt
da haben hier bis jetzt noch nie gesagt
und wir werden irgendwelche
maßnahmen gegen die nato-mitglieder
eingreifen und meine
kollegin hat schon studio ist vor kurzem
erklärt wenn
putin
in der ukraine gewinnt dann werden die
potenz ambitionen keine grenzen haben
und sich auf basische staaten
verbreiten also das haben aber nicht wir
gesagt sondern unsere
kollegen die uns unterstellen wir planen
angriff auf baltischen staaten oder
holen das gehört ja zum alltag in der
britischen außenpolitik
die also das steht vollkommen in der
tradition
sich heute ist
möglich was wir uns noch gestern nicht
hätten vorstellen können sagen sie mit
der ich glaube daran dass es zu einem
atomkrieg kommen kann vielen dank
ich will daran nicht glauben ich glaube
nicht an ich möchte sie darauf
aufmerksam machen dass diese atom
problematik im kontext der ereignisse in
der ukraine in den letzten jahren
die jetzt eben verschafft sind dieses
atom problematik wurden in diesem
diskurs eingeführt ausschließlich die
westlichen vertreter vor allem die der
nato länder ich möchte sie auch daran
erinnern dass auch die lisa krass wir
reden heute von der dame ganz viel hat
gesagt sie schließt ein konflikt
zwischen nato und russland nicht aus wie
kann man auch sagen wären gedanken
kommen ich bin auch daran dass auch der
herr stoltenberg der ich glaube es schon
ein bisschen zu autark agiert und seine
aussagen nicht mit allen nato-ländern
abstimmt und berg hat gesagt nato kann
atomwaffen in osteuropa stationieren
novanatur es möchte und der halle 3 anm
ein französischer kollege hat erklärt
dass putin muss sich daran erinnern dass
frankreich auch atomwaffen hat und
apropos auch der französische
wirtschaftsminister hat neulich stolz
erklärt derwesten erklärt einen totalen
krieg gegen russland total krieg
so haben nicht die franzosen gesagt
ihrer zeit
auch der präsident biden ich habe mich
schon auf dieses beispiel berufen weil
es ja gesagt wurde ist eine alternative
gab
zu den sanktionen der hat gesagt die
einzige alternative ist der dritte
weltkrieg das heißt im unterbewusstsein
kommt es immer wieder hoch kommt es
immer vor wir haben davon noch nie
geredet aber natürlich macht es stutzig
wenn der westen frei nach der sigmund
freud immer wieder zu diesem thema punkt
2 letzte fragen
zwei letzte fragen der kollegen
aus kasachstan der kasachische präsident
auch kasachstan als standorte für die
verhandlungen zwischen russland und der
ukraine vorgeschlagen ob ist dieser
vorschlag noch in frage kommt und man
kommt es zu der nächsten
verhandlungsrunde der konfliktparteien
also russland wie ich bereits am anfang
dieser pressekonferenz gesagt habe ist
sehr dankbar allem die aus gut gemeinten
gründen vermittlung vorschlagen bei der
lösung von dieser schweren krise dieser
innere ukrainischen krise wird durch wir
sind all denjenigen die bereit sind
dabei zu helfen dass wir eine lösung
finden können indem wir interessen von
allen seiten berücksichtigen und eine
balance der interessen
herbeiführen das wichtigste ist dass
diese vorschläge die die gesagt wir sind
davon überzeugt unsere türkischen
freunde
machen dieser vorschläge aus dem westen
überlegungen dass diese vorschläge von
der ukrainischen seite nicht missbraucht
werden weil das ist tradition bei der
ukrainischen seite durch effekthascherei
reale handlungen zu ersetzen wir haben
schon zu den minister verhandlungen
zahlreiche ersatz vorschläge gemacht als
es noch verschlossen dass hoffnungen gab
im zusammenhang mit dem minsker prozess
dann wurde auch die türkische
variante vorgeschlagen als ich hinter
sehen stehen die verweigerung der
eigentlichen arbeit wie gesagt die durch
effekthascherei zu ersetzen stuhl und
habe wenn es ein mehrwert gibt er wieder
präsident putin gesagt hat das haben wir
mehrfach ins gespräch gebracht wir sind
zu unterschiedlichen formaten bereich
dieser formate müssen aber nicht
für plauderei zusammengerufen werden und
eine abschließende frage
von bbc der außenminister
mahnte russland wirklich ernst mit der
suche nach einer verhandlungslösung
aber wenn das der fall ist was haben sie
denn heute auf den tisch gelegt welchen
fortschritt haben sie erzielt und
zweitens wenn ich damit wie können sie
über diplomatie und waffenruhe und
verhandlungen sprechen wenn
gleichzeitig entbindungsklinik
bombardiert werden so viele zivilisten
sterben
zum dritten mal werde ich nach dem in
bildungs krankenhaus gefragt und zum
dritten mal wird man nicht meine antwort
er hören sie hören auch jetzt nicht zu
wobei sie wahrscheinlich kein russisch
verstehen
ich habe gerade gesagt zum dritten mal
werde ich nach diesem im bildungs
krankenhaus gefragt das heißt sie haben
nicht zugehört als ich dazu schon
geantwortet habe zu diesem konkreten
fall das war auch bei ihrer ihrem medium
bei bbc und bei den anderen die haben
das zum headliner gemacht die in diesem
zwang heraus das haben wir bereits am 7
märz beim sicherheitsrat erklärt da gibt
es wieder kinder noch ärzte oder
krankenschwester es ist besetzt von den
kämpfern auch von den soldaten von
badalona softer hast die haben es zu
ihrem stützpunkt gemacht so wie sie es
ukraine weit überall machen wo sie
zivilisten menschen zu lebendigen
schildern machen also ganze wohnblöcke
zur lebendigen schülern machen indem sie
da ihre artillerie unterbringen und von
drüben die positionen der russischen
truppen
schießen
aber unsere vorschläge waren ernst
gemeinten wir haben bereits am 15
dezember unsere vorschläge auf den tisch
gelegt auch zum aufbau von dem
sicherheitssystem dabei keinem neuen
sicherheitssystem sondern es geht um die
umsetzung gott davon worüber wir
mehrfach behandelt haben auf dem süßen
politischen ebenen
verhandlungsrunde oder in astana 2010 da
stand doch schwarz auf weiß ja jedes
land hat einrechnen
müsse für sich auszubilden aber keiner
darf eigene sicherheit zu
behaupten indem sicherheit von anderen
ländern gefördert wird sie haben die
diplomatie erwähnt dass manche spitze
der diplomatie das war unterschrieben
von den präsidenten und
regierungsstatthalter von russland und
für unseren partnern entschuldigung auch
von der freien welt die unterschriften
waren keine
eigene sicherheit behaupten
der sicherheit anderer länder kein land
keine organisation hat recht oder
anspruch zwischen vorrang auf
europäischem boden wie es nato ganze
gruppe macht indem sie auch recht der
von anderen ländern gefährdet als unser
vorschlag ein abkommen abzuschließen
zwischen russland und nato
die grundsätze die ich gerade hier noch
einmal erzähle aus den dokumenten die
bereits angeschrieben worden sind die
noch mal stehen würden in einem solchen
abkommen zu sehen denn für beide seiten
anstatt von einer antwort auf diesen
vorschlag haben wir vom hass
rothenberger eine kleine meldung
bekommen und von herrn ball auf eine
kleine meldung jeweils eine halbe seite
darauf stand macht euch keine sorgen wir
sind bereit zu verhandeln und straßen
und die tatsache dass die abkommen
bereits unterschrieben worden sind auf
dem höchsten ebene das war nicht von eu
und nato unterschrieben sondern von
einzelnen staaten
das bedeutet dass weder großbritannien
noch die anderen länder das lässt uns
dass die diese entscheidung einfach
dirigiert haben dem generalsekretär der
nato ihre rechte ihrer verpflichtungen
und jetzt ist er dafür zuständig diese
schwere dieser versprechen
auszuführen oder nicht auszuführen das
wurde mit der diplomatie gemacht von
ihren vertretern den vertretern des
westens natürlich wollen wir auch jetzt
eine diplomatische lösung wir wollen
dass die diplomatie die fragen löst aber
diesmal
haben wir ganz klar erklärt dass die
demobilisierung der ukraine notwendig
ist die identifizierung der ukraine ist
ebenso notwendig und das kann nicht mehr
aus gezögert werden denn die gefährdung
die da gebildet wurde eine gefährdung
der russischen föderation unmittelbare
militärische gefährdung aber auch
kulturelle und
informationstechnische gefährdung eine
zivilisations gefährdung für die
russische föderation
die war schon ganz klar und deutlich
dass nicht mehr aus zypern ja klar wenn
wir mit anständigen menschen weiter
verhandeln werden und ehrlich verhandeln
werden wenn es so wäre wäre auch heute
alles anders gelaufen und gelöst auch
die fragen der sicherheit waren schon
gelöst aber solche partner sehen wir
nicht die bereit wären ehrlich mit uns
zu verhandeln
obwohl die versuche gab es früher und
ich hoffe dass die
regierungschefs im westen die jetzt sich
so aufregen darüber was in der ukraine
löw dass sie endlich verstehen und
verinnerlichen wie existenziell die
gefährdung für die ganze europäische
sicherheitsarchitektur ist ist und dass
sich deren untätigkeit und verweigerung
die abkommen von früher umzusetzen wir
wollten nie einen krieg wir wollen auch
jetzt keinen krieg wir wollen diesen
krieg beenden
im interesse von den beiden republiken
die 2014
den umsturz den blutigen umsturz in der
kleinen tief nicht mitmachen wollten
kinostart ganz stolz beobachtet wie
menschen am lebendigen leibe verbrannt
werden in odessa die haben zentrum von
der stadt lugansk bombardiert dieser
regionen kilo hat acht jahre lang
geschossen und bombardiert
dörfer schulen kindergärten
im soll jetzt kommt lukas dafür gibt es
etliche beweise ist wir unsere
journalisten
und ich verbeuge mich vor den
journalisten die auch da gefallen sind
haben jeden tag sieben tage die woche 24
stunden pro tag das alles gezeigt und
dokumentiert dabei haben westliche
dokumentierte entschuldigung westliche
journalisten kaum die republiken und
jetzt konto ganz
besucht vielmehr haben sie gesagt
alles wäre gar nicht so schlecht dabei
die meisten opfern war nicht auch naldo
griechischen seite sondern im jetzt und
lukas ein einziges mal war bbc
journalisten sind für feiertage da
gewesen in donetsk lugansk und haben
eigentlich ziemlich objektiv von drüben
berichtet aber dass dieses thema das
thema der aggression des regimes gegen
das eigene volk im osten
was die verletzungen von internationalen
abkommen anbelangt verweigerung der
ausführung von in resolutionen dass
jemand im westen darüber berichtet dass
systematisch daran kann ich mich nicht
erinnern
wenn man liest was sie heute schreiben
über die ukraine was jetzt abläuft und
wenn man das vergleicht damit was sie in
den vergangenen acht jahren berichtet
haben ich glaube eine solche analyse
wäre sehr aussagekräftig was den zugang
zu informationen und die kultur der
berichterstattung anbelangt ich
wiederhole noch einmal es geht geht um
entscheidungen die auf dem höchsten
ebene auch von 12 getroffen worden
sondern sie sind unter westlichen seite
nicht eingeladen eingehalten vielen dank
damit ist die pressekonferenz von herrn
lauf zu ende
so dass waren live die pressekonferenzen
der außenminister der ukraine und
russlands nach den verhandlungen die
heute im türkischen antalya
stattgefunden haben nach wie vor bei uns
im studio ist generalleutnant ag klaus
oelshausen wir werden gleich mehr
einordnen welche sicht auf den ukraine
krieg lavrov soeben präsentiert hat aber
zunächst mal die analyse der beiden
aussenminister haben sie da irgendwelche
fortschritte erkennen können in richtung
waffenstillstand humanitäre korridore
ich konnte keinen fortschritt geben weil
hertha profi eben noch mal betont hat
das ja gar nicht zuständig ist für
solche verhandlungen sondern das die an
der russischen grenze stattfinden werden
und er eigentlich ich nehme das mal
salopp nur dem türkischen außenminister
der nun eine aktivität herbeiführen
wollte keine absage erteilen wollte
immer über uns konkret wurde hat ja
gesagt dafür bin ich das nehme ich mit
das nehme ich zu meinem präsidenten und
wir wollen gerne reden wenn es ein
mehrwert hat kam auf wenn die interessen
die er ja formuliert hat der russen
vorangebracht werden die gefahr die ich
sehe ist dass bei dieser art von diktion
und bei der dem willen auch im westen zu
einem ende dieses krieges zu kommen er
plötzlich mit einem krieg noch sozusagen
politische gewinne macht gegenüber der
ukraine und dass wir der ukraine er noch
zu reden ist ein oder anderen kompromiss
zu machen den sie eigentlich als land
als volk nicht machen können das ist
eine große gefahr die ich im augenblick
sehe es sind diverse andere verhandlungs
formate angesprochen worden die
verhandlungen auf etwas niedrigerer
ebene in weißrussland wo ja schon der
eine oder andere korridor humanitären
korridor ausgehandelt wurde aber am ende
in aller regel dann nicht zustande kam
und darauf ist auch angesprochen worden
auf die möglichkeit eines treffens
zwischen zielinski und putin da hat er
sich ich würde mal sagen sehr hinhaltend
geäußert aber wenn sie eindeutig man
trifft sich mit putin wenn sie lenski
bereit ist den förderungen der russen
nachzugeben wenn also entmilitarisierung
verbot von irgendwelchen allianzen das
sozusagen auf dem papier steht und dahin
fortschritt erzielen da gibt es sofort
ein treffen mit dem präsidenten putin
vor das aber so ist wird weiter
alarmiert bzw gekämpft aber es scheint
so dass die russen doch auch erkennen
dass sie einen ich sag mal klaren
militärischen sieg nur bekommen können
wenn sie in brutalster weise das land zu
bomben- und das glaube ich können sie
für sich selbst nicht wollen wegen des
landes aber auch wegen der folgen die
das für die gesamte internationale
gemeinschaft ihnen gegenüber hätte jetzt
haben wir ja sehr ausführlich gehört in
der pressekonferenz vom russischen
außenminister lavrov wie die russische
sicht der dinge ist oder zumindest wie
die russische sicht ist die russland
gerne hätte dass wir die die ganze welt
einnehmen also der ukraine krieg ist
keine aggression russlands sondern
letztendlich eine aggression der nato
und der ukraine die sich von der nato
instrumentalisieren lässt gegen russland
was ist davon zu halten also das ist die
erzählung die sie haben weil sie
natürlich gemerkt haben spätestens seit
2014 dass die bevölkerung von russland
weg tendiert weil sie das natürlich
nicht ertragen konnten was da passiert
ist und die beiden grundfesten in den
astana erklärung der erwähnten ist
einmal die freie wahl der bündnisse für
jeden einzelnen souveränen staat und
dann der hinweis auf die unteilbare
sicherheit so nach dem motto die
entscheidung des einen die souveräne
darf nicht gegen die
sicherheitsinteressen des anderen gehen
und die sicherheitsinteressen russland
sind so definiert das natürlich eine
freie entscheidung der ukraine nicht ich
werde den nennen die frei entscheiden
wie sie seit 2014 das betreiben dann
verstößt das gegen die
sicherheitsinteressen russlands und
damit muss russland im zweifelsfall wie
wir es hier sehen eingreifen die beiden
papiere die er im dezember angesprochen
hat an die nato an die usa waren
natürlich als ultimaten so formuliert
dass er wusste dass die abgelehnt werden
und damit hatte er schon sozusagen für
sich selber die begründung dass er jetzt
militärisch technische aktionen von
seinen generalen die er vorgeschlagen
bekommen hat durchführt so muss man
diese konstruktion die wir heute nun im
ergebnis eines sehr sehr viel brutalen
krieges sehen einordnen kleiner hinweis
noch an dieser stelle wir warten auch
noch auf an die pressekonferenz des
gastgebers des türkischen
außenministers hier sehen wir einen
blick in den saal die türkische fahne
also sobald der türkische außenminister
davutoglu
da seine pressekonferenz abhalten wird
schalten wir dahin
ein ganz zentraler satz lautet ja im
krieg stirbt zuletzt zuerst die wahrheit
wir haben hier jetzt einen ganz
komplizierten fall uns hat in den
letzten tagen immer wieder beschäftigt
dieser beschuss des kinderkrankenhauses
in mariupol da nach diesem beschuss
eines krankenhauses eines
kinderkrankenhauses ist jetzt darauf
immer wieder drei bar gefragt worden und
er hat immer dieselbe antwort
präsentiert das war gar kein mehr
kinderkrankenhaus in betrieb mehr das
war schon längst der sitz der as often
brigaden in mario und jetzt haben wir
beide natürlich keine möglichkeit das zu
recherchieren ich sag jetzt einfach mal
liebe zuschauer liebe zuschauer das wird
in den nächsten tagen von vielen
recherchen tubbs untersucht werden aber
zunächst einmal würde ich einfach mal
hier aus dem fenster lehnen und sagen
das gehört in die strategie der
desinformationskampagne der russischen
regierung die da wo es zu
menschenrechtsverletzungen und und
schlimmerem kommt immer sagt fake news
vor allen dingen werden sie immer sagen
dass die
armee oder die milizen diese
zivilpersonen wenn sie denn getroffen
werden ja als schutzschilde vor sich her
treiben wo sozusagen selbst schuld sind
sozusagen provozieren weil der kampf der
russen gegen die milizen und gegen die
armee es aber weil die sich sozusagen
mit zivilen personen umstellen führt das
natürlich auch zu entsprechenden
verlusten die aber nicht den russen
anzurechnen werden sondern denjenigen
die die schutzschilde sozusagen benutzen
letztendlich liefert das auch eine
erklärung warum russland durchaus
interesse haben könnte dass da korridore
gebildet werden die die zivilbevölkerung
aus den großstädten wie stoff und kiew
evakuiert weil das am ende natürlich ist
der russischen armee erleichtert diese
städte zu erobern ohne die
entsprechenden schäden oder verluste
weil der zivilbevölkerung zu haben und
in dem zusammenhang muss man schon mal
überlegen sind das korridore um die
zivilbevölkerung
hinaus gehen zu lassen oder sehen dass
korridore die eher einer vertreibung der
zivilbevölkerung aus diesen städten
dienen um dann sozusagen mit den
entsprechenden schlägen der armee diese
städte entweder zur bomben oder sie in
besitz zu nehmen und das als faustpfand
zu haben um in verhandlungen zu gehen
wir haben jetzt von lavive auch wieder
diese russische position gehört der die
russische spezialoperation das wird ja
nicht krieg genannt die läuft nach plan
das was wir in aller regel hören ist da
läuft überhaupt nichts nach plan
der russische vormarsch stock wie
schätzen sie als
militärexperte dass ein wie sehr ist der
russische vormarsch ins stocken gekommen
oder inwieweit ist das normal ich sage
es mal salopp auch die usa hat im kampf
im irak einige tage gebraucht bis man
bagdad erobern konnte es gibt natürlich
nach dem grundsatz der plan den man hat
der gilt nur solange bis der erste
schuss fällt und dann ist alles eine
so ein system von von aushilfen und
sowas wird es natürlich auch in russland
leben sicherlich haben sie noch ihren
grund planen vor augen aber er wird
natürlich ständig durch die realität am
boden verändert ob er so verändert dass
die russen mit mit zwei gründen zur amt
zum einlenken kommen entweder weil es
die unwahrscheinlichkeit des erfolges
gibt oder weil die kosten für sie auch
gerade durch die sanktionen so groß sind
dass sich das festhalten an diesem krieg
szene nicht mehr lohnt können sie aus
dem wie der krieg bisher verlaufen ist
in der ersten 14 tagen erkennt welche
strategie russland verfolgt also ich
denke noch wollen sie den militärischen
erfolgen haben sie werden das auch
versuchen man muss sehen ob wir schon
erkennen können welche weiteren kräfte
die russen in der lage sind nach zu
führen oder ob sie mit ihren
luftstreitkräften raketen streitkräften
einfach diesen diesen terror diesen
bomben terror gegen die zivilbevölkerung
so verschärfen dass im grunde genommen
die bevölkerung sagt sie hier sie wollen
ja unabhängig sein aber diese
bombenkrieg diesen die rakete wollen wir
auch nicht mehr ertragen und sozusagen
sich einen stillhalte abkommen
unterwirft weil sie diese
brutalen krieg nicht mehr ertragen
können das könnte eine der option sein
die andere option ist dass er erst mal
hat was er hat vetter complete und nun
mal die sache so stehen lässt und dann
gucke was ihm die ukraine und was ihm
die westliche welt zugesteht als gewinn
durch diesen angriff da müsse aufpassen
dass russland da zusammengezogen hat ein
militär sowie sie das beurteilen können
ist das ausreichend um die großstädte in
der ukraine zu besetzen und wäre das
auch ausreichend um die ganz gesamte
ukraine zu besetzen eine besetzung der
gesamten ukraine kommt nicht infrage sie
behaupten ja auch immer dass sie das gar
nicht wollen können sie auch nicht wohin
mit 100000 oder 150000 banken kann man
nicht ein das zweitgrößte land europas
sozusagen unter besatzung haben sie
haben keine zustimmung in der
bevölkerung da wo sie sind wir kommen
keine russischen von der privat dafür
von der zivilbevölkerung sei willkommen
ukrainische fahren vor den fahrzeugen
der russen also sie erkennen auch dass
ihre vermutung wieder hoffnung dass
diese regierung ja nur die anderen
unterdrückt hat und jetzt alle
russischen fahnen wieder sozusagen zum
tragen kommen sich nicht einstellt also
insofern müssen sie schon ihre ihren
plan oder ihre vorstellung von dem was
sie erreichen müssen korrigieren aber im
augenblick kann sie eben einige faust
ferner in der hand sie sind im land sie
brauchen sagen wir ziehen uns ja nicht
zurück die nato-länder werden vielleicht
noch warten ließen aber sie werden
natürlich nicht dazu
wichtig dabei lassen das zurückdrängen
der russen zu verfolgen ob das mit
sanktionen gelingt dass die russen dort
einlenken vor ort das halte ich für
ziemlich fragwürdig jedenfalls nicht in
schneller zeit folge halten sie es für
denkbar aus ihrer sicht dass die
russische armee darauf verzichtet die
großstädte mario pohl charkow und kiew
zu erobern oder gehört das zu den
minimal zielen russlands die russland
auf jeden fall verfolgt also bei mario
pohl bin ich nicht sicher wenn das so
stehen bleibt bestehen bleibt und sie
haben die brücke so krim dann ist die
hauptziel auf dieser seite erstmal
erreicht bei kiew ist das anders weil
das natürlich wenn sie das nur belagern
dann ist das natürlich ein - weil es sie
nicht gelingt mit der regierung
sozusagen in eine situation zu schaffen
boden die regierung rief ein denken muss
insofern wenn die kiew nicht in die hand
bekommen und einen kampf in der stadt
der ist für die russen auch mit panzern
oder gerade mit panzern besonders
schwierig da haben die einzelkämpfer
diejenigen die panzerabwehr erwarten
haben und andere was kleine waffen haben
immer einen vorteil weil sie das land
kennen weil sie die stadt kennen da sind
die russen in einen großen nachteil also
für mich ist das offen ein wirklicher
angriff auf die stadt wir glaube ich
nicht aber ein einkesseln der stadt
irgendwie sozusagen auszuhungern das
halte ich für denkbar und wenn wir
nochmal bilanzieren was wir da heute
gehört haben aus antalya russland wird
mutmaßlich erst dann zur wirklichen
friedensverhandlungen bereit sein wenn
russland den eindruck hat mit
militärischen kommen wir nicht an unser
ziel ja und wenn sie die politische
davon ausgehen können auch wegen der
haltung in der westlichen staaten dass
sie ihre hauptziele in der ukraine in
sachen die militarisierung keine
bündnisverpflichtungen neutralität die
ihnen in die hände spielte wenn sie das
durchsetzen können
generalleutnant ag klaus olsen
herzlichen dank dass ihr uns durch
diesen vormittag begleitet haben und wir
können jetzt gleich noch mal einen blick
werfen nach antalya wir sehen hier den
raum in dem der türkische aussenminister
gleich seine pressekonferenz abhalten
wir das zeigen wir ihnen natürlich live
bis das soweit ist können wir ihnen noch
nachtragen wir hatten ja live gezeigt
das statement des ukrainischen
außenminister school war nach seinem
treffen mit lawrow auf was wir ihnen
noch schuldig sind ist der teil in dem
der ukrainische aussenminister die
fragen der internationalen presse
beantwortet hat und das zeigen wir jetzt
zunächst einmal
möchte ich dem
türkischen außenminister dafür danken
dieses treffen organisiert zu haben das
war nicht einfach aber er hat es
geschafft
diesen ersten kontakt zu vermitteln
zwischen
den außenministern von russland und der
ukraine seit dem beginn der russischen
aggression gegen die ukraine dieses
meeting dieses gespräch war
einfach und zugleich schwierig einfach
weil minister lawrow im wesentlichen
seine traditionell negative über die
ukraine vorgetragen hat schwierig weil
ich
mein bestes gegeben habe um
zumindest eine diplomatische lösung zu
finden für die humanitäre tragödie die
sich vor unseren augen entfaltet auf dem
schlachtfeld in den belagerten städten
die tragische situation entwickelt sich
gerade in der stadt mario pohl am
asowschen meer
die stadt wird aus der luft bombardiert
sie liegt unter artilleriebeschuss
und ich kam hierher
mit humanitären zielen
ich wollte hier vereinbarungen erreichen
für die einrichtung humanitärer
korridore in die stadt mario pohl unter
hier aus der stadt hinaus aus der stadt
hinaus für zivilisten die aus der
belagerten stadt aus dem gebiet von
angst und kampf zu fliehen wollen und
einen humanitären korridor der es
ermöglicht humanitäre hilfsgüter in die
stadt zu bringen leider
war minister lavrov nicht in der lage
sich selbst darauf zu verpflichten aber
er wird mit den entsprechenden
autoritäten in russland darüber
konferieren wir haben auch die frage
einer 24-stündigen waffenruhe
aufgeworfen um die drängendsten
humanitären probleme zu lösen
wir haben keinen fortschritt in dieser
frage erzielt wie
es scheint werden diese entscheidungen
von anderen in russland getroffen
wir haben vereinbart
unsere bemühungen fortzusetzen
um eine lösung nach lösungen zu suchen
für die humanitären probleme im land ich
bin bereit mich erneut zu treffen mit
minister labor in diesem format wenn es
aussichten gibt auf substanzielle
diskussion
und auch die ernsthafte suche nach
lösungen ich glaube wenn zwei aus
münster sich treffen dann
haben sie per definitionem das mandat
über frieden sicherheit und andere
fragen zu verhandeln das das ist in ja
von ihren parlamenten anvertraut worden
und von der politischen führung und ich
bin bereit
auf diesem wege weiter zu verhandeln mit
dem ziel den krieg in der ukraine zu
beenden
das leid der ukrainischen zivilisten zu
beenden und
unser
gebiet von den russischen
besatzungstruppen zu befreien
meine erste frage
betrifft wir treffen hatten sie den
eindruck gewonnen dass die angriffe
weitergehen werden nach dem treffen und
das führt zum an der nächsten frage
haben sie ein versprechen erhalten eine
zusage im
hinblick
auf
militär auf kampfflugzeuge
aus usa oder anderen ländern für ihren
kampf gegen die besatzung
nein wir haben nicht über militärische
lieferungen in die ukraine gesprochen
auf meine initiative hin haben wir die
meiste zeit damit verbracht über
humanitäre fragen zu sprechen weil ich
glaube
das ist die höchste priorität für
diplomatie aktuell nämlich erleichterung
zu schaffen für all denen die leiden und
ich habe an außenminister lavrov auf
sehr konstruktive art appelliert das war
nicht immer einfach für mich ihm
zuzuhören aber ich habe an ihn mehrfach
appelliert
mit der bitte
dringend die humanitären probleme
anzugehen
zum ersten teil ihrer frage mein
eindruck ist dass russland nicht
in der position ist aktuell jedenfalls
nicht eine waffenruhe zu vereinbaren sie
wollen die kapitulation der ukraine und
das werden sie nicht bekommen die
ukraine ist stark die ukraine kämpft die
ukraine hat die ursprünglichen
russischen pläne zum scheitern gebracht
und wir sind bereit
ausgewogene diplomatische lösungen zu
suchen um den krieg zu beenden aber wir
werden nicht kapitulieren
eine frage von der bbc darf ich sie
zunächst zu dem 4 der 24 stündige
waffenruhe befragen sie haben gesagt
herr wolf sei nicht in der lage gewesen
dort eine entscheidung zu treffen dass
er eben nicht der entscheidungsträger
ist haben sie irgendein vertrauen dass
es einen gerade 24 stündige waffenruhe
geben kann und wir wissen das herpes
koch sagte die inversion werde stoppen
wenn es ein bekenntnis der ukraine gebe
nicht die nato zu nicht der nato bei zu
treffen und wie angekündigt
[Musik]
journalisten und journalistinnen
wir bedanken uns erst dass sie bei den
versammlungen heute mitgemacht haben
diese wissen ist wir haben
wir haben anstellung macht um das blut
und die tränen wie in der ukraine
fließen zu stoppen wir sind der meinung
dass
diese in diesem krieg einer der gewinner
sein wird und die verlierer sind die
unschuldigen zivilisten
haben
regionalen länder und wie menschen
schaden erlitten
wir haben unsere anstrengungen
fortgeführt um hier eine friedliche
lösung zu finden und haben auch deswegen
mit allen seiten
kontakt aufgenommen wir haben auch mit
herrn putin uns mit herrn selensky
kontakt aufgenommen
ich habe auch mit meinen kollegen locker
und cool aber
oft gesprochen
wir haben beide seiten eingeladen in
unserem land zusammen zu kommen
das haben
die beiden politiker auch hier zur
sprache gebracht
es ist bedeutend dass das hier im rahmen
des anteil der diplomatischen forums
stattfindet
wir haben hier eine moderation rolle
übernommen
und aber auch unsere
ansprüche
stehen auch noch
wir haben
unseren anspruch darauf dass die
humanitären hilfen gemacht werden
denn jeden tag fließt blut jeden tag
werden läufe menschen verletzt
krieg ist natürlich im krieg sind
natürlich die menschen immer die
leidtragenden
es muss ein
ein waffenstillstands herrschen ein
humanist in humanistischer
waffenstillstand ich muss eine
humanistische
[Musik]
korridore
geschaffen werden
wir haben es auch am
eigenen leibe erfahren als wir unsere
bürger aus dem land
zurück geholt haben wir haben das auch
unterstrichen dass in mario bros
ein waffenstillstand
gemacht werden muss
ist russland in diesen gebieten
mario pohl beispielsweise
da uns natürlich sind auch ukrainische
drucken
und
es ist möglich dass zivilisten in
lebensgefahr
[Musik]
dieses meeting
das erste treffen auf
außenminister ebene wir erwarten keine
wunder hier von dieser vor diesem
meeting aber es ist zumindest ein anfang
es ist auch angesprochen worden
dass
so ein treffen in
auf
staatspräsidenten ebene
stattfindet
hat sich auch dafür ausgesprochen
auch unser staatspräsident herr erdogan
hat sich dafür ausgesprochen
und auch putin ist nicht abgeneigt
die haben es aufgenommen
dass die ukraine insbesondere darauf
bestanden hat dass euch ein meeting in
der türkei stattfindet während russland
darauf bestand dass
dieses meeting in belarus
stattfindet
der kollege hat mir am telefon auch noch
mal gesagt und
das 4
so ein meeting ist natürlich die einzige
option für die türkei das hier beide
länder auf eine friedliche lösung
arbeiten
und deswegen danken wir
den beiden
stars präsident den beiden
außenministern
und herrn kohl ära
sprechen wir unseren dank aus dass sie
die einladung von herrn schatz tresen
erdogan und von mir angenommen haben
haben jetzt im nebenraum das antalya
diplomatie forum und dort wird es
weitergehen aber ich werde versuchen
ihre fragen jetzt noch zu beantworten
herr minister sie waren auch bei dem
treffen von cholera und herrn lauro
dabei
wie war die atmosphäre dort
merkel hatte nach dem treffen gesagt
dass nicht alle seine forderungen
erfüllt wurden wie sehen sie das kann
das denn in der zukunft passieren
natürlich finden die auseinandersetzung
weiterhin statt
bewaffneten auseinandersetzungen
weiterhin statt aber dennoch
wollen
beide seiten
wollen beide seiten dies auch
unterbinden aber es die atmosphäre war
sehr zivilisiert und nicht sehr nervös
oder
aufbrausend
das war ihre zweite frage
ich habe eben schon in meiner rede
gesagt es ist zumindest hier jetzt eine
erste ein erstes treffen
und
kennen beide minister
und auf dieser ebene hatte ich auch
keine
keine erwartung dass alle probleme
gelöst werden
wir wünschen natürlich auch dass diese
weiter geht's diese bieten es
weitergehen
wir freuen uns auch wenn es woanders
stattfindet aber wir müssen der türkei
stattfindet sehen wir natürlich auch
dass das vertrauen in uns weitergeht
würde ich es in kanada werde dieses jahr
geplant wir warten jetzt auch noch mal
auf die ergebnisse in einer zukünftigen
in einem zug riss ihm treffen in belarus
und somit haben wir auch da das meeting
beendet
ist es einfach geworden aus der krise zu
kommen
nach diesem treffen und was war der
wichtigste punkt der erreicht wurde ich
habe das eben auch gesagt es war das
erste treffen auf außenministerebene
[Musik]
niemand erwartete dass alle probleme
gelöst werden aber es musste auch ein
anfang gemacht werden
im folgenden wenn alles
[Musik]
auftreffen auf basis von weiteren
treffen
werden natürlich die politiker eine
basis finden und das habe ich eben auch
unterstrichen
eine offene antwort
ist das ein positives treffen gewesen
und kann das hier
weitergehen
solche treffen
es war natürlich ein positives treffen
und hat unsere erwartungen
auch
erfüllt
für die nächste zeit dass auch weitere
treffen auf ministerebene und auf
höherer ebene
stattfinden können
die ukraine hat gesagt
und wenn von der usa und von der türkei
garantien gegeben werden
dass die ukraine dann neutral bleiben
wird in zukunft wohl hat die ukraine
gesagt und was sagen sie dazu was stimmt
das
ich möchte nicht viele details
reingehen aber wir haben hier
bei unserem treffen
wurden viele sachen unter anderem auch
die neutralität kleines der ukraine
angesprochen
sie wissen auch dass die ukraine dort
die usa und auch die türkei um garantien
gebeten hat
die türkei wird natürlich das machen was
sie
für was wie viel zu was sie fähig ist
ich bedanke mich
ja soweit also die stellungnahme des
gastgebers des